las personas que hacían fila para
recibir sus vacunas en salisbury
blackburn en reinounido disfrutaron de
la música de órgano y contemplaron la
arquitectura de las catedrales mientras
esperaban su vacuna contra el comic 19
fue absolutamente maravilloso me alegré
tanto en recibirla especialmente en un
escenario maravilloso como este
6 me siento un poco más segura vivo por
mi cuenta así que ya sabes es importante
los decanos de estas dos poblaciones
elogiaron el papel que los centros
religiosos desempeñan en la oferta de
vacunas a la comunidad una evidencia
para los clérigos
todos los días durante 800 años dos
veces al día hemos dicho nuestras
oraciones aquí y rezamos día a día por
la curación de la nación por la salud de
la ciudad por el bienestar de nuestra
comunidad mi noche
se pide mucho play así que ser capaz de
desempeñar este papel positivo en esta
etapa de la emergencia de salud pública
es un maravilloso regalo que espero que
seamos capaces de ofrecer y compartir
el gobierno tiene como objetivo vacunar
a los cuatro niveles de mayor riesgo los
ancianos los clínicamente vulnerables y
los trabajadores de la salud y de la
asistencia social de primera línea para
el 15 de febrero algo que requeriría más
de 2 millones de vacunaciones a la
semana hasta este sábado casi 36
millones de británicos han recibido la
primera dosis de la vacuna lo que
representa el 55 por ciento de la
población total